I Michael Scott am signing up with an
online dating service thousands of
people have done it and I am going to do
it I need a username and I have a great
one
little kid lover that way people will
know exactly where my priorities are at
my producers are apparently on all the
weird sex apps you know the what the
swipey ones I assume they're mostly on
Grindr but I think some of them are the
other ones too and so they need my
advice on how to interact with their
romantic partners and I'm here to give
that because I'm the love doctor of the
daily wire so take it away
I got 99 problems and a patriarchy
explains at least 86 of them
waka waka chubby hard swear why are
these people saying they're chubby and
fat that's that to me suggests that
these people feel bad about themselves
they feel that they've let themselves go
but they've also been told by the
culture that it's wrong to want to
improve your appearance or your attitude
or your behaviors in any way so we've
made a cult out of behaviors that are
harmful to us and unappealing to us and
we we're stuck in that we're stuck in
that rut because because we're told that
anything that's normal or traditional or
naturally attractive is bad chubby hard
swearing well then don't swear you know
just don't do it Whiskey Drinking always
10 minutes late first of all do women
really ever drink whiskey nope nope they
do it they're the kind of girls who say
I'm you know I'm not really friends with
girls I'm mostly friends with guys I'm
not a regular girl I'm a cool girl but
like no there are a handful of women who
enjoy whiskey I know and I I think
they're sincere about it they're a
handful of women who enjoy cigars I
think they're sincere about that too but
at least seven times out of ten when a
girl says oh I want a whiskey or I want
a cigar or something they're just trying
to fit in with the men but the men don't
want another male companion if we if I
wanted to hang out with a man I'd hang
out with a man every single man is going
to be a better man to hang out with Than
a Woman This Way the gases will expand
out of the rocket
if I want to hang out with a woman then
you know I'm expecting a woman not a man
always 10 minutes late yeah kinky I
don't know is there a definition of
kinky it's it's like adding the word
interesting hey I'm really interesting
and can appeal to your lust
okay all right I'm on Tinder you uh my
lust has been appealed to trust me bye
okay yeah sure lady uh polyamorous okay
so all of those mean the same thing I'll
do whatever I have no inhibitions please
love me that's all I mean it's very sad
I don't mean to make fun of it it's sad
that women feel the need to to do this
and say I'm extremely promiscuous and
I'll just do anything that titillates
you please love me no no I I no no sale
pretty
because we should have a culture now
like we previously had where men would
love women they'd make commitments to
women and you'd love more about women
than just like whatever depraved acts
they'll do to you and other people but
we're in a much shallower age where
women feel the need to do that and
cheeseburger chicken taco cheese like a
lot of food no one-nighters it's good
boy I'm not the kind of drum you play
one time wow so that's it so it's no
one-nighters which should be like hey
I'm not that's what that's what
that traditionally would say which one's
a
you need to take me on a few dates first
or maybe even believe it or not we'd
have to get married first but that's not
what she flips it she goes no
one-nighters you're gonna want me for
more than one night no
no I don't think I will it's it's the
cardi B thing the WAP thing I'm gonna
sew debase myself for you that you'll
definitely call me back at least one
other time that's pretty sad uh
overeducated and amazing in bed see
there you go I called it wow I totally
called that uh do not hey hi how's your
week treating you me or I unmatch you
immediately I provide paid profile
advice super like me to discuss fees
that's interesting because it's not this
isn't prostitution in that she's not
selling herself for sex she's
at the very least selling Tinder
Consulting kind of luring the men in
with all this I'm kinky I'll do whatever
I want this might be a real dating
profile tour it might just be an
advertisement wow what a Twist at the
end right now go to expressvpn.com
Michael YT it is extremely important to
protect your online privacy with a VPN
choosing a VPN that you trust
equally important I can say with full
confidence that expressvpn is the best
VPN on the market here is why number one
expressvpn doesn't log your online
activity they've even developed a
trusted server technology that makes it
impossible for their servers to store
any data at all
2. speed expressvpn does not slow down
your user experience you can even stream
HD videos with zero buffering number
three expressvpn is incredibly easy to
use just fire up the app and tap one
button to connect it's not just me
saying this Business Insider The Verge
many other Tech journals great
expressvpn the number one VPN in the
world protect yourself with the VPN that
I trust use my link expressvpn.com
michaelyt today get three months free in
a one year package
expresvpn.com Michael YT letter y letter
T expressvpn.com Michael YT head on over
there today I am Polly am polyamorous I
guess e-n-m what's enm is that one of
those stupid personality profiles like
I'm an empg or whatever what what use
the force Michael ethical non-monogamy
oh yeah the lady doth protests too much
me thinks I only cheat on my husband in
the most ethical way possible okay with
one partner already currently open to
social distancing methods of dating
uh phone calls Holo it's hello oh hello
like that mask wearing mandatory on
first date but not on the second date
BLM no trumpsters no cops in military
I'm buy slash pan slash demisexual boy
you're busy have cats love dogs it's a
sidebar I have found the people not
people who have pets a lot of normal
people have pets but the people who get
really obsessed about their pets the
people who make having pets really key
to their lives the people who
don't have children because they just
want to have not because they can't have
children just because they don't want
children they only want to have pets
those people tend not to like humans
very much
non-smoker
social Drinker light THC user light THC
user either you're puffing on the ganj
or you're not I'm allergic to cigarette
smoke no you're not nobody's allergic to
cigarette smoke every single space in
America and throughout the Western world
really throughout the entire world until
very very recently was just a cloud of
cigarette smoke and no one was allergic
to it then it's just a way of saying I
don't want you to smoke but I want to
pretend that there's a medical thing
I've fallen and I can't get up shut up
Obama 4 20 okay as long as it's not your
whole personality Supernatural Marvel DC
karaoke goth club nights tabletop games
chronically ill chronic I'm sorry to
hear that I don't sometimes people just
say these things but they're not really
true but maybe this person's chronically
ill no that would be said chronic pain
if you don't understand these we
probably won't get along if you don't
totally perfectly understand me me me me
and look the other way Julia cooking and
coffee mother of two babies virgin I
love my husband
lesbian
because she seems like a keeper
I think listen I hope that I remain
married to my wife till the very last of
my days I don't think divorce is
possible I will never under any
circumstances divorce my wife and I pray
to God that she outlives me but if in
some Bizarro alternate universe I ever
were back on the market somehow
Julius getting the call 32 lives in
Universal City pansexual 10 miles away
most things you'd want to know about me
put some Sims Doja Ari in your mind and
ears
does anyone know what that means they're
all contemporary singers Michael Sims
Doja Ari yes he's a singer okay they all
are oh and Sims is a singer too okay got
it shorter hair is current bit of a Girl
Interrupted moment a few weeks back
racists slash Pro trumpers slash white
sis Nails slash elitists of other
ignorance igniters kindly swipe left
then move to your own Planet maybe that
was the old right wing thing the old
right wing thing for maybe 10 years ago
was I'm just I just want to be left
alone and you do you and I'll do me I
think we're past that I'm no longer in
the you do you and I'll do me
and you'll be the pan Tran thank you
ma'am and I'll be normal and we'll just
all kind of whatever and every
everything will be neutral
baby I've seen enough Tinder and this
stuff has to go my favorite one
The One That Got Away
the love of my Tinder life
she was Jew in them well that doesn't
work anyway Julia she's my pick that's
the one so I sing a song
[Music]
oh yeah